hey what's up this is dr. John Delaney
with Ramsey Network we are continuing
our talk about anxiety in the last video
if you haven't seen it check it out I
told you that anxiety is just a fire
alarm it is not the problem
these crazy worlds we've set up for
ourselves these ideas of success and
who's winning and how busy do I have to
be and what do I have to achieve and who
do I have to compress that's setting off
our fire alarms man the alarm is not the
problem our lives are our disconnected
relationships are and so we think about
anxiety we need to remember it's just a
fire alarm it's just trying to tell us
something but it is real and those
alarms are powerful and they take over
your heart they take over your thoughts
they take over everything and so if you
are faced with anxiety if someone you
love is just laid low with a heart rate
that's taken over with thoughts that are
just spinning out of control what do you
do if you find yourself struggled
anxiety I'm gonna give you a couple
things you can do in the short term and
a couple of long-term things you can do
to address anxiety one of the things
that makes people incredible is that we
don't need real fear threats to set off
our alarms so it doesn't actually have
to be a tiger at the door we can just
think about a tiger and boom our alarms
go off so the first thing you do when
you feel anxiety taking over is you
write down your thoughts most of us have
automatic thoughts that immediately jump
into our heads paint a picture of what
the next two days two weeks two months
two years is gonna look like and then
our alarms set off here's an example of
an automatic thought when anxiety takes
control you show up to work late right
and your boss says hey man I need you to
be here on time you're always late and
you show up late again and then you get
an email from your boss sending to talk
to you about it you're late again and
boom the anxiety alarms are off to the
races you're gonna go in that meeting
and not only are you gonna get fired but
your boss is gonna tell you to your face
you're worthless you're a loser you will
never work again and then you start
thinking about your family and your
family's got starved and probably your
younger
they're gonna die too because you will
never get another job
that's anxiety that's when your
automatic thoughts of I should have been
on time and I'm have to pay the piper on
this one boom goes off to the races so I
want you to write down your thoughts and
do a quick inventory is it true or my
making it up is it real or not real and
do a quick inventory of that list okay
number two make a list of what you can
control and what you cannot control and
let the things you can't control
go can you control showing up on time
yep
can you control going to your boss and
saying I'm sorry here are the three
things I've put in place that I will
never be late again
can you go home to your wife or to your
husband or to your kids and say dad's
got a problem being late and I'm sorry
and here's the things I'm gonna do to
never be late again
and I'm gonna need y'all's help in that
as I transition in my life yeah you can
control those things can you control if
your boss just decides enough is enough
you're fired
no can you control if you're gonna get a
job tomorrow or the next day or the next
day no and so worrying about those
things right now
not helpful worry about the things you
can control and let the other things and
go number three take control of your
body
this may sound cheesy but research
suggests my life supports this idea of
taking deep breaths and controlling our
breathing stopping personally I follow
box breathing inhale for four seconds
hold for four seconds let it out for
four seconds just chill for four seconds
and then you breathe it in again
some folks say do that for two minutes
three minutes five minutes but
controlling your parasympathetic nervous
system slow it down
okay also before you ever get to this
anxious moment taking care of your body
like exercising eating right getting a
full night of sleep those are things you
do to keep your kitchen from ever
catching fire in the first place so that
when you it's like building another
outlet so you don't to load everything
up right take care of your body
number four connect with a friend or
group now when your alarm starts
spinning don't text don't email call go
see somebody face to face our bodies are
designed to Co regulate themselves with
other people I wish it wasn't the case I
wish I could be the Lone Ranger
maybe I'm from Texas dude I wish we
could all just pull ourselves up by our
bootstraps and figure everything out on
our own we can't it's a lie you've got
to have other people so when you know
the anxiety alarms are starting to spin
up you can hear them getting louder and
louder you may not always be able to see
the smoke in your kitchen you may not be
able to see which rooms are on fire call
somebody talk to somebody bring somebody
into your home and say I need some
support I need some help my alarm is
about to go off again
they're starting to sound you gotta have
other people and number five is
gratitude
every day but especially when your
alarms are starting to kick off take
that same piece of paper that you wrote
your thoughts and feelings down on take
that same piece of paper that you wrote
what you can control what you can't
control flip it over and make a
gratitude journal quickly write down
five sentences that begin with the words
I am grateful for I am grateful for my
family I am grateful for my wife I'm
grateful for my job I'm grateful for my
health whatever it may be I keep my
gratitude journal with me all the time
every day and I know that sounds crazy
but the research shows people with
gratitude people who daily express
gratitude our healthier have better
relationships they sleep better they are
more well and they have less anxiety you
may think it's woo woo you may think
it's cheesy try it do it every day for
30 days and see what happens so those
are five things you can do right now
right when you feel the alarms going off
in the next video I'm going to talk to
you about some things you can do long
term to help fireproof your kitchen
fireproof your house and truly connect
with other people as you can see I'm
committed to reframing anxiety I'm
committed to helping people reclaim
their power over their thoughts their
actions and to help people change their
lives anxiety is not a death sentence
it's a fire alarm and there are things
we can do in the short-term like we
talked about today and things you can do
in the long-term this is dr. John
Delaney with the Ramsey Network
subscribe send this to somebody who's
struggling and I'll see you soon